[Music]  so let me hear everything that happened  my own family to slit my throat now one  of them voted ragab all three of our  members voted for it well obviously  they're trying to take me out if they're  trying to take you all right Wendell and  Dom went for Angela because they wanted  the power away from me and that was a  big mistake  look if we flip with you and me and then  those four for six to two and it's gonna  be Dumber for one no Timmy was an  opportunity to jump in with the Malolos  we have the votes three three hours late  I'll make him yeah you think that he has  that I'd always yeah he showed us that  they come with a seashell that string  it's a straight into string with the  shell I told you guys he's a master  manipulator  he's kind of like Chris versus Dominique  right now you know those two are  definitely lots betting head I like you  I like you I like you I like you and I  like myself